how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to the channel we have a
bunch of new leaks for venom 2 today
including some leaked photos and a
leaked video which seems to be carnage
torturing somebody we actually have a
few videos that lead up and connect with
one another so let's start with Cletus
taking a car for a joyride
[Music]
video actually ties into another leaked
video that we got about a week ago we
can see Cletus outside of his car and
officer or detective comes up to him
tells him to raise his hand and we can
clearly tell that the officer shoots him
but the carnage symbiote comes out so
it's clear at this point that Cletus has
the carnage symbiote and he's driving
around town like he doesn't care about
anything because he now has the symbiote
and is basically unstoppable and this
video is a perfect example of him
getting shot but not taking any harm
whatsoever due to carnage and then we
have another new video that connects to
this but first I want to thank raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
and supporting the channel and the
community you've probably heard of red
shadow legends before as they have over
10 million downloads and you've probably
heard it from an ad as well I've slept
on rate for a pretty long time even
though I've been interested but now
after playing it I kind of can't put it
down the graphics in this game are way
better than any mobile game really
should be in fact they're pretty much
better than most console games and as a
lover of RPGs I do love the story mode
and I do love all the characters that
you can choose from and upgrade it's one
of the most interesting story modes I've
ever played in any game before and you
can play pvp and now it's even available
on desktop if you play you can find me
under the Nick at the cosmic Wonder and
if you're quick enough you can join my
clan so what are you waiting for go to
the video description click on the
special links and if you are new player
you will get two hundred thousand silver
plus one free champion tree filler all
your treasure will be waiting for you
here when you log in good luck and I'll
see you there
so those previous two videos link to
this video
and if you notice down at the bottom
there is somebody holding a prop of
Carnage's arm obviously most of carnage
is going to be CGI but not all of him
and for the sake of filming they do have
props and we can clearly tell it's his
arm so somebody's holding up a prop of
Carnage's arm for one scene and then in
the same exact scene they take that away
and bring in who appears to be detective
Mulligan and in this video we can see
him just get whipped around you can
clearly tell that carnage has his hands
on him now there's something very
important to know about Patrick Mulligan
or detective Mulligan and that is he is
the host to Carnage's symbiote son toxin
carnage gives birth to the symbiote
toxin and it inhabits Patrick Mulligan
so we could quite possibly be sane
another new symbiote in venom - toxin in
fact this could be where detective
Mulligan does get the toxin symbiote
carnage may not know that he
accidentally implanted the symbiote on
detective Mulligan now in the comics
both carnage and venom know that toxin
will eventually go on to become a
stronger symbiote than either of them
and what happens as venom and carnage
end up making a deal with each other
that they can stop fighting each other
to go and kill toxin however they failed
to do so because toxin teams up with
spider-man and talk to him would later
on go up to team up with spider-man
again and help the Avengers now it's
already been revealed that Tom Holland
has met with Sony about a venom to cameo
and we know that Sony wanted Tom
Hollands spider-man to appear in the
first venom but Marvel Studios didn't
want that to happen however we now have
a new deal between Sony and Marvel and
it's most likely that Tom Hollands
spider-man will be in venom - and if
they do introduce toxin and spider-man
into venom - this is even more proof
that the Sony spider-verse and the MCU
could be colliding so if any of this
happens and toxin is actually introduced
in venom - there is a possibility that
venom and carnage could actually team up
together after all Cletus Kasady
is a psychopath and now that he has
carnage basically infinite power he
probably doesn't want anybody else to be
stronger than him and he's willing to do
whatever it takes to defeat him even if
it means teaming up with venom
temporarily to kill toxin then he can
kill venom after and speaking of Cletus
Kasady we have some new leaked photos of
him as well as you can see the red wig
is gone and what's left is a very comic
accurate Cletus Kasady I know a lot of
people were really worried about that
red wig when we saw him in the
post-credits scene for venom but
honestly here he looks perfect
and we also have a photo of Tom Hardy
and Woody Harrelson of course both
playing venom and carnage together on
set and they look to be having an
awesome time the chemistry between them
is said to be extremely good which of
course as everybody knows makes for a
great movie carnage is definitely
Venom's number one enemy and we're
finally seeing him on screen and since
we know Cletus is going to be breaking
out of the Ravencroft Asylum and we know
that shriek is confirmed to be in venom
too as well and there's a possibility of
spider-man appearing in venom two it
looks like we may be getting part of the
maximum carnage storyline which could
mean we could possibly be seeing venom
and spider-man team-up to face carnage
which of course would make perfect sense
because as we know carnage is stronger
than venom so he's definitely going to
be needing some help especially if
carnage has shriek alongside him but let
me know what you think about these
leaked videos and about these leaked
photos be sure to hit that like button
and subscribe for a chance to win an
Xbox one or ps4 I'm picking a winner at
five hundred and fifty thousand
subscribers as always thank you all so
much for watching woof woof